Where's the gratitude?
I've given you an amazing life.
I made you.
What is this?
Are we just gonna keep staring at eachother?
Marker
I wanted to.
Yeah, you should call one of your easier women.
Roxanne from the coffee shop.
Julia From the. Sorry. I literally forgot all their names.
Julia from the.
Dry cleaners sorry,
I really get the giggles on it.
Maya.
If you can't sell the ones we actually have
and then I’m gonna have to.
You can't.
Yeah.
If you can't sell the ones
we actually have.
I would have to have some.
Maya, if you can't find the....
Sorry, guys.
Tongue tied.
Linda, does
the Beanie Baby collectors, radio update
on YGN.
WGN
WG-YN
That’s what I want to say.
No! I have, like, four bloops now.
Okay.
I told my sick
daughters I'd be back as quick as I could.
Then I waited here for longer than a.
If I could raise one eyebrow.
I’d do it right now.
I. I.
Look, I'm a hectic business man, that that.
Okay from the Top.
We’re gonna go again.
You’re one in a million Robbie Jones
No one's ever calling cut.
Are we the hotel?
That was a short drive.
Maybe they called cut.
And we can hear it.
We do need the radio. Actually, on.
Genius is 1% inspiration. 99%.
I got lost.
I can see you.
I've relied on men in the past.
Sorry.
I won't do the hair thing. It's too real.
I love you in recession.
It's a great. Show.
CUT
Do you know what you want.
Teeny weeny Beanie Babies.
We are just two pretty ladies.
I got to keep that Beanie baby.